bon alors on est un peu de jus de citron
encore un fait sucre et on remue tu veux
goûter
c'est un 10 mois ci c'est long alors
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans tu sais et du
pamplemousse de leur range et du citron
on va l'appeler les trois agrumes vous
savez pourquoi
parce que la séance en repli toit sans
neige et les agrumes si si c'est l'effet
monstre musulmane alors vous êtes très
savant il y en a un autre là qui
constitue avec de la tomate de et
carottes et du citron du dans tu vois ça
a la couleur
mais qu'est ce que vous faites et ben on
s'amuse beaucoup
figure toi qu'on fait des cocktails ah
oui enfin qu'est ce que ça a été des
common pudil à des cocktails et bien
c'est un mélange de jus de fruits ou de
jus de légumes et puis on sucre aux
salles ont revu et en aval c'est
exactement comme le gloubiboulga mellick
et d'un on prend toutes les choses on
les mélange très très fort et on n'a pas
de bravo casimir c'est tout à fait ça
bonjour qu'est ce que c'est françois ou
que c'est joli et c'est bon aussi
je crois que ça vous plaira à tous les
deux qu'est ce que tu as mis dedans
monia c'est un mélange de fruits
exotiques
c'est à dire qu'ils viennent d'ouvrir de
l'âge il est très bien mais parfois il
en sait ce qu'il ya dedans y'a du jus de
papaye hardy papaye
qu'est ce que c'est c'est pas de grosse
pomme noms des heureux des grenades
c'est un genre de grenade y a du jus de
goyave 6
sorte de point c'est une sorte de poids
il ya jus de passiflore lcd grenadille
ou fleur de la passion et aussi du jus
de grenade le dos à la grenade
c'est très bien mais 50 et roncq ans et
mes yeux messieurs avec de la moutarde
dans la chanson écoute quasi dire des
choses épouvantables ont prévu de
regarder la couleur regarde rebelles on
dirait presque la couleur framboise
je vois mais c'est plus qu'important
dans un cocktail est ce que c'est le
goût ou la couleur mais les deux un bon
cocktail qui a de plus une jolie couleur
c'est quelque chose de très agréable
alors je vais allez vous préparer des
cocktails avec des couleurs comme vous
n'en avez jamais vus soit je suis
inquiète
qui sait il paraît que la famille des
casimir us que c'est d'un jardin secret
avec des fruits extraordinaire encore je
m'appelle allons vous fait manger l'oise
expérience en france or vous avez des
couleurs étaient déjà vides ou le
laminage et à la mine saveurs et des
cocktails comme vous n'en avez jamais
rabat alors casimir à se violer ce bleu
se verse est orange ça il faut dire que
ce sont des couleurs extraordinaires
mais tu leur as donné dé nous bien sûr
comme en appel du celi cidre de glace
appelle ça ça s'appelle alors il
s'appelle la wii il s'appelle gazon
gazon gazeau c'est vraiment un drôle de
nom il se violer la lui la sapin avant
je ne lui ai pas encore trouvé de nom a
et b moi je vais l'appeler violette et
c'est celui que j'ai choisi tu veux
y'a très bien oui après quoi françois
lequel choisi q ha et bien moi je vais
prendre cela en ont bien celui ci la
nature quoi
très bien ils ont comment s'appelle
cette fameuse loi celui là bas il
s'appellera à du nom que tu vas lui
donner ben moi j'appellerai ça audemer
c'est pas au bon si tu veux oui alors
vous êtes prêt à vous présenter
attention hein
ces cocktails doivent se boire d'un prêt
c'est important
alors 1 2 3 rolala mais c'est bon qu'est
ce que c'est ignoble
mais julie qui m'a tellement dit que ce
qui était important dans un cocktail que
c'était la couleur
alors j'ai pris ma boîte de peinture et
j'ai fait ouverts en mille ans jean de
la peinture jaune et de la bleue j'ai
fait le turquoise en bilan gens du bleu
et du vert
j'ai fait le violet en mélangeant la
facture avec de la peinture bleue vais
mieux je vais tomber malade
[Musique]
on